benvenuti sorretto da oggi dovremo
salvare il natale
e kiprono parco rettoria di robots come
sempre lasciato un mi piace qua sotto
mettetevi comodi prendete i boccoli
inizia nostra vittoria
sarà cambiato mangiare allora abbiamo in
colle remi che carini tutto di una
cartina prezzo sale su matrici da lassù
questa è anche sulla renda io mi metto
parte da smith
cosa dovremmo fare in questa storia ma
se volete scriveteci nei commenti che
cosa vorreste per questo modo o che cosa
avete già chiesto che chiude gli occhi
con ricami al mese per questo natale
scrivetecelo nei commenti era stato un
mi piace per portarvi fortuna se non
avete visto le scorse ass.i.pro.v di
natale andate a vederlo dopo questa
perché sono bellissime pronti per
partire eri così dove siamo nel
villaggio di natale gambe valori
bellissimo
stiamo andando
wow sta nevicando tantissimo dico io ma
tempo fatto di totale guai mercato che
questo due non nevica e come non
possiamo costruire dobbiamo fare gli
angeli neve dice la battaglia di nese
presto entriamo in riscaldiamo
avete un minuto mamma della nostra mamma
vitale sicuramente starà cercando
qualcosa da voi mi stanno aiutando la
cioccolata biscotti ci sono biscotti
prima di andare a letto mettiamo i
biscotti e il latte per babbo natale
dove dobbiamo metterli vicine dinamica
preghiamo c ok dov'è il cammino da il
cammino e quadri gatte v ok allora lo
sta portando dice di mettere il quale
tavolino ma il cammino was peggio altri
frutti
dentro spegnete il cammino sta arrivando
sta tirando col vassoio bravo è stato
ora andiamo a dormire babbo natale
diverso latte con i biscotti primo
minuto per andare a dormire io
ok presto dormi ma io sto dormendo della
seduta
eppure lì non sai
eccolo vitale di fronte a me buonanotte
certo quel personaggio
l'avete sentito anche voi perché tutto
brucia non vedo niente forse se un
intruso nella casa ma stiamo aspettando
babbo natale squadra prima di natale
dobbiamo trovare l'interruttore aver
accendere la luce nella stanza oppure vi
sarà una torcia dai sbrighiamocì
interruttore
aiutarti se babbo natale e tu sei
rimasto incastrato lino ok sono riuscita
ad arrivare anche al di sotto dove babbo
natale è andato via non equa si è rotto
una gamba vedi uno è caduto dentro il
cammino dice dobbiamo trovare rudolph la
renna andiamo via presto sbrighiamoci
abbiamo solo 20 secondi dove rudolf
forse dietro queste case qualcuno sta
correndo la seguivo gli altri giocatori
è sicuramente sapranno meglio di noi
dovere
eccola lì la vedo che sta scappando
ma siamo lontanissimi
mancano solo pochi secondi
no non è qui no abbiamo allora ma
abbiamo sbagliato
questi regali dobbiamo fare qualcosa
forse aprire questi regali guarda questa
notte is bisogna portarli bisogna
recuperare ciò che i regali che sono
caduti forse la salite dovrebbe essere
qua nella foresta ok dobbiamo recuperare
altri tre anche rudolf che praticamente
ha perso i regali dalla slitta 6 trovate
le strisce colorate lecce anche nudo ora
possiamo riportarlo babbo natale si
arena dice sito preferito babbo natale
stato fila per tanto tempo
ci stiamo spiegando che ha avuto che si
è rotta una gamba scendendo dal camino
ok grazie per averci aiutato
dobbiamo trovare rudolf lascia in giro
perché stava accertando del cibo rai da
che parte andato l'ultima volta che l'ho
visto stava andando giusto in quella
caverna lì dopo il lago ghiacciato
dobbiamo stare attenti attraversare il
lago ghiacciato forse dobbiamo prendere
qualche pezzo di legno per andare
attraverso il lago sa che può fare anche
qui si può fare una specie di zattera e
dobbiamo trovarne altri 30 eco rudolf e
lazio
vedi il naso che si illumina ok ok però
da fare in possiamo impostare sembra che
adesso possiamo andare da rudolf
ok come ho fatto a finire l'ipres
sbrighiamoci
è quello che faremo
grazie per avermi salvato zaini ma moto
quarte non può fruttato per voi nuovo
preoccuparti seguici e per tornare
indietro con noi non sono così sicuro
che queste i pezzi di legno sono così
solidi non preoccupatevi posso volare ma
poi si costituirono volando è ma accusa
un momento noi che marica di calmarmi
quando tu potevi volare
poteva far partire al polo nudo saliti
tutti sul sulla slitta dobbiamo
consigliare a tutti questi ragazzi
perché babbo natale si è fatto male
quindi noi prendiamo il posto di babbo
natale con una bella e così vitale posso
guidare io lo slip no non mi fido o
meglio che decidono le reti di rudolf
che la guida forza ecco gli altri si
sono seduti sulle renne pronto il rotte
dal volo amore 2 1
non ci posso credere che stiamo volando
con la slitta di babbo natale
peccato che buio non si vede tanto pure
un bellissimo
e stiamo per piantare sia per i
propulsori rossi più triste
ne esce un punto esclamativo forse
dobbiamo dobbiamo andare con renali
questo era super divertente ora dice che
dobbiamo andare consegnare i regali
nella mia casa dovrò quindi questo
dobbiamo salire sul sulla canna fumaria
sia attraverso la ecco fatto battere una
casa
siamo nel cammino ma è gigante questo
cammino da esprimere come prescindendo
ecco il regalo
abbiamo tutti i ragazzi sulla testa a
castiglione non possiamo toccare il
pavimento
altrimenti si scopriranno sappiamo
camminare solo nei pezzi di legno così
non ci svegliamo ma dobbiamo camminare
po sopra poi mettere il regalo sotto
l'albero non commettere qualche mio
metterlo qua ho chiesto salendo quassù
quello di non essere scoperta che a ok
non ho quasi un e aborto qua
che succede anch'io ho consegnato dai
sbrigati ok attento a non toccare il
pavimento no
ma è tipo mission il prossimo non
consegna dei regali che sica può venire
l'ansia
ok siamo tornati a prima tu sei una
macchina fotografica reinvestire subito
più mandare attenti attraversare la
strada non fatevi prendere dalle
macchine ok il giusto attenta
ok quindi adesso dobbiamo andare
sull'altra casa sì sì berto vediamo se
c'è il tempo può venire l'ansia fare il
lavoro di babbo natale
allora vediamo c'è un albero dobbiamo
messo molto sotto albero ma possiamo
andare sul pavimento
sembra che che sveglieremo nessuno
perché c'è il tappeto ok ok dobbiamo
mettere il regalo fa messo che non
appena ci sono altri regali che dobbiamo
mettere mano ma anche tu ok non messo
dovevo mettere un regalo anche ok nella
stanza dei bambini presto vedremo dove
sarà su immagino p
fate schifo
solo consegnando i regali parte ci
stiamo facendo un favore o no ci
riescono ancora a per un pelo non vi
abbiamo canzone perda mai stati sul mare
ma dobbiamo prendere altri regali quindi
sediamoci nella slitta eccoci qua è
difficile da consegnare a tutti i
ragazzi non capisco perché i genitori ci
insegue dobbiamo essere visitatori che
bello mi battevo sono gli altri
giocatori non sono state elezioni ma si
interessa è che stiamo arrivando da
babbo natale per prendere gli altri
regali così dobbiamo entrare nella
fabbrica di regali di babbo natale
abbiamo di prove
ma ecco gli altri giocatori ti ti ti ti
ti ti
benvenuti one
bellissimo guarda tutti regalare loro va
bene se babbo natale non ti preoccupare
st buon natale se è sempre ok ho sempre
bene e noi siamo i suoi nei di medici e
lo stiamo aiutando ok abbiamo bisogno di
aiuto per rimettere i regali sulla
slitta ci può aiutare a certo che carini
che sono questi è
perfetto
prendi tutti i regali e bisogna metterli
in questo ruolo penso
che dovremmo prenderli qua ecco ho preso
un regalo e bisogna metterlo fa e non
trascura four ten dobbiamo metterlo
quale dobbiamo forse qui guarda qui
dietro a rullo che così lo trasporta ho
capito
ok qua mai a fare qua quindi doveva
metterlo qua che non capiti direttamente
alla slitta perfetto se mancano
tantissimi guardato iannucci e bruciato
33 regali water e super divertente e mi
hai rubato il regalo aiutateci hemphill
meno male non siamo solo in due
presto
ok ne mancano pochi ci siamo quasi ci
siamo quasi ok il primo frase tutto e
forse questo è un cast all 1 che sarà no
passo grazie però non ci avete ancora
una casa da visitare ok a te torniamo
nella stretta per continuare a salvare
il natale vuoi super divertente questo
gameplay sedia voci ecco io sono sentita
con un altro giocatore quindi tu devi
andare nelle reti e sarò preso l'arma
andiamo nell'ultima che stiamo remando
peggiori regali che bello e va dove si
appoggiano bene le carte di natale la
carta rotolando nello spazio ok mettiamo
i ragazzi sotto l'albero dobbiamo
mettere quelli del colore giusto però
che c'è sotto l'albero giusto
io non ho visto quindi devo andare
nell'albo della mostra ecco l'albero
rosso ok ho messo un regalo nell'albero
rossa e cioccolata presa in un altro
regalo verde ok lo mettono di un albero
verde quindi ogni volta cambia con la
suspense avviene un po catervo
sbrigativi se siano così fatto era matto
uno verde qui questo è un osso equa
abbiamo finito poi uno brucia blu
anch'io sì sì ne servono ancora un po di
blu forse se abbiamo fa quasi fatta ne
manca uno blu lo sta portando lei e ora
li abbiamo tutti ci avremmo fatto
diversi bravi torniamo velocemente a
casa prima che ok si sia l'alba e siamo
in volo che profila babbo natale siamo
stati bravissimi e perché questa volta
di la dei regali anche noi però siamo
atterrando per il prezzo sembra che il
sole stia sorgendo
richiamo woods vediamo se torniamo a
casa prima che i nostri geni sono timori
no è vero perché noi siamo andati fine
di nascosto nel tempo pregate
pregate prima controlliamo se babbo
natale sta bene vero l'abbiamo la sola i
problemi adesso i miei film mi hanno
aiutato e hanno curato grazie per averci
aiutato avete salvato il natale aspetta
poi c'è un regalo per voi ben
[Musica]
sapete che io collezioni badge di tutele
ski promo di rob lowe siccome uno dei
giocatori è arrivato per primo avranno
in regalo d'oro luce perché no ma io ho
avuto il regalo rosso guarda io regalo
rothe erde bianco e bello tornare in
camera da letto i capi prima che si
sveglino hay e matt è ancora lì questo
perché dobbiamo aprire legali lo puoi
aprire a natale non è giusto mi ha molto
al base il motore non devo anche preso
un regalo giusto per divertente ora vi
lasciamo qua 4 caselli su cui cliccare
per le nostre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite